everybody it's Charlie we got to talk
about a new Captain Marvel trailer we
have a schedule update and news about
the Avengers 4 trailer it is gonna be
huge next week there's a new round of
that imax ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video
big news first obviously as this teaser
implies they're gonna drop a new Captain
Marvel trailer tomorrow night during
Monday Night Football of course I'll do
a video for it the big thing about this
trailer is different from the last
teaser that they dropped is that it's
more of a story based trailer and gives
you a better idea for what's going on
like there's a lot of confusing dialogue
there's a little bit of voiceover from
Carol Danvers but unless you're a big
Captain Marvel comic book band and
you've been following the movie for a
long time you don't really get a sense
for what the movie is about that's what
this next big trailer is intended to do
give you more of her backstory on planet
earth like you see her walking out of
that Air Force hangar it just meant to
mirror the shot where she's walking with
Star Force up to that spaceship but the
confusing way with which the last
trailer proceeded in a very nonlinear
fashion with a lot of false memories
like her not knowing where she came from
not remembering her life on planet Earth
I think I had a life here I'm not sure
you get a lot more dialog a lot more of
the scrolls and a lot more of what's
going on with the actual plot of the
film like oh they're Scrolls hiding
amongst us you just saw him walk up on
the beach in the last trailer next
trailer we'll probably get to see Talos
inside shield talking to Nick Fury
outside chance they'll have some funny
dialogue from Coulson and clues some
small snippet from him then a little
more of her life as she grows up and
becomes an Air Force pilot and then runs
into those creepy poland' outer space
that caused the accident that lead to
her getting powers because we just found
out who Jude Law is officially playing
and there's a big twist in the movie I'm
interested to see how the trailers
handle this too because they try to give
away as much information as possible
without being spoilery but once you know
who the characters are playing you have
a pretty good idea for how things are
gonna play out we also haven't got a
whole lot of Star Force footage those
are actually some really interesting
characters Jemma Chan looks pretty
fantastic in her makeup if you don't
recognize her she was just in crazy rich
Asians but she's playing min irva who's
a villain in the comics but from the
trailers you've obviously seen in the
videos that I've done they're changing a
lot of that in a subversive way so we
can talk more about that when we see the
actual trailer footage so I don't wanna
get too far ahead of ourselves
the big
about the Avengers 4 trailer is that a
lot of people are now theorizing that
the reason why we're doing Captain
Marvel on Monday and supposedly the
Avengers 4 trailer on Wednesday morning
is this because they're gonna feature
some Captain Marvel footage in the
Avengers 4 trailer and because we
haven't really got a whole lot of her
movie yet they just want to help set
that up so one thing at a time like you
learn about Captain Marvel then you
understand why it's so important for her
to be in Avengers 4 then you see her in
Avengers 4 so that's probably one of the
biggest reasons why we have not seen
Avengers 4 footage yet it's just because
they want to familiarize you with
Captain Marvel and her movie is coming
in March a couple months before we get
Avengers 4 anyway but the thing about
that Avengers 4 trailer just expect it
to be every bit as cryptic as that first
Infinity Ward teaser remember like it
gave you no idea what the plot was there
was a whole bunch of missing things they
took a bunch of gems out of Thanos's
gauntlet when he was in Wakanda and cap
was grabbing it there the only real
scenes that we could have called faked
were them running at the end of the
trailer with the Hulk and everybody in
Wakanda that scene appeared nowhere in
the film and obviously Hulk did not
become Hulk in Wakanda he was still in
the Hulkbuster but there was that
deleted scene of Thor holding
Stormbreaker up obviously they wanted
like a really badass scene but the funny
thing is is that you don't even have to
slow the trailer down you can still see
it it lingers on the shot long enough to
see that he's not holding up anything so
it was just a big joke like everybody
realize okay they just want to give a
spoiler away for what Stormbreaker is
gonna look like so part of the fun of
Avengers 4 is the idea that we know that
they're going to be wearing some of
their original Avengers costumes from
the Battle of New York I wouldn't be
surprised if they try to mix in some old
footage and pass it off for a new stuff
but it'll be pretty easy to tell what's
new and what's old so that'll be part of
the fun like seeing alternate versions
of the characters and trying to decide
whether or not they're reusing footage
from old films or if they shot it
completely new bringing it back to round
2 Captain Marvel talking about that
Avengers infinity war post-credit scene
with Nick Fury's pager pretty easy
assumption that the Captain Marvel
post-credit scene or at least one of
them is gonna be a tag where she
receives that page and goes oh [ __ ] I
need to get back to earth there was also
a lot of deleted scene videos that I've
been doing one of the cool things is the
Russo said that there was a version of
the movie where Captain Marvel did show
up
the end but they got rid of that pretty
early in the process it was during this
interview when they were talking about
it I think the arcs are fantastic so
we're really really proud of being able
to introduce Captain Marvel on this one
I think they made the right call there's
just too many big reveals for them to
blow their wad in that first film so
they wanted to save some really cool
stuff for later on like save the big
reveal for the Captain Marvel movie so
you see her for the first time when we
saw that trailer then that idea that
they have to cap off ten years worth of
Marvel films it's not just a single
phase like you had with age of Ultron
like okay obviously we have to move
these characters forward we have to
bookend the last couple years of Marvel
movies they have to book at every single
Marvel movie that they've done so far so
biggest news on the docket is that yes
the Russos did talk about Secret Wars
I'll play that clip in a second because
it's pretty cool just them name-dropping
oh yeah we would totally come back to do
Secret Wars like they're just gunning to
do something with those x-men and Fox
characters and the idea that even though
Captain America is at the top of all of
our death predictions list Joe Russo
said himself the Chris Evans is not done
with Marvel after Avengers 4 so let that
throw you for a loop and think about
what it might mean for his character
I've already done a video breakdown of
all the big stuff that they talked about
at their big special panel they did a
couple days ago so I'll link that at the
end of this but this is them talking
about Secret Wars
what do fans have to do to get you to
helm a Wolverine and spider-man movie
and have Hugh Jackman Captain engineers
as two years ago Mark Ruffalo's oiled
the movie
what the hell was your reaction when he
said some stuff hired them
so everybody let me know in the comments
Captain Marvel and Avengers 4 trailer
what are you guys most excited about
this week and I know I haven't talked
about it a whole lot but supposedly
there might be some news about the
Avengers for a game happening at the
game awards later this week the Russos
of all people are presenting an award at
the game Awards like it's weird for them
to go to a video game event and do
something really big while all this
Avengers stuff is happening so a lot of
people have theories that it might have
something to do with the Avengers game
that we haven't heard anything about in
a long time big Avengers triple-a game
on the level of Spider Man ps4 so what
will happen is is I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post that Captain Marvel
trailer video tomorrow leave your
requests in the comments below click
here for my breakdown of that big
Avengers for infinity war event and
click here to learn all about who Jude
Law is playing during the Captain Marvel
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]